[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
ERIK DEMAINE: All right.
Welcome to practice
problem session 3, 006.
Today, we are going to go
through a bunch of problems,
which you should have already.
I was thinking of skipping
the very first problem,
because it's just
a mechanical thing.
If we have time at the end,
we can come back to it.
But there's not really any
insight I can give you in how
to approach this problem.
It's just, do you
understand hashing?
So I want to go into the
more creative problems first.
Let's start with problem
3.2, hash sequence.
So I'll just read it.
And then our first task is
to convert the word problem
into a concise formal algorithms
thing we need to achieve.
Then we need to come up with
ideas for how to achieve it.
And we need to
check the details.
That'll be our general pattern.
So this problem
says, hash tables
are not only useful for
implementing set operations,
they can also be used
to implement sequences.
Remember from lecture 2,
we have a set interface,
which is about querying
items by their key
and sort of intrinsic
order that's
about the items themselves,
versus a sequence
interface that we started
out with, with linked lists
and so on, and arrays,
where we're given an order,
and we want to
maintain that order.
And that order may
not have anything
to do with the items themselves.
So that's what we call
an extrinsic order.
We're told what the
order is by saying,
insert this item after this one,
or append this one to the end,
or prepend it to the beginning.
So in lecture last week, we
saw hash tables implement sets.
And let me just remind you
some things that they can do.
So we have, on the
one hand, set hashing.
So we're going to
need this in a moment.
This is just a
reminder from lecture.
We can build one in
linear time expected.
We can find an item in
constant timed expected by key.
And we can insert
or delete an item
in constant expected amortized.
OK, so this is a black
box that we're given.
And the problem statement
says that, imagine you're
given a hash table
as a black box, which
means we're giving a thing
that behaves just like a--
thank you, 2.
We're given something
that is a hash table.
But it's black box in
the sense we're not
allowed to reach in and change
the implementation details.
We're supposed to use it as is,
just by calling its interface.
So in particular, we're
giving these three operations.
I'll maybe also use iter to
iterate through the items.
So we're allowed to build
something in linear time,
find, and insert and delete in
constant expected amortized.
And what the
problem is asking is
to build out of
this data structure
a sequence with
particular time balance.
So this is what we call
a reduction in that we're
going to convert--
I guess technically, we're
reducing the sequence problem
to the set problem,
because we're
showing how to solve the
sequence problem using the set
problem.
But the way we'll think about
it is in the other direction.
We're given a data
structure that solves set.
And we're going to convert
it into a data structure that
solves sequence.
So given that we already know
how to do this from lecture,
we're going to learn
how to do this.
This is teaching you new
stuff in a problem set.
So the specific
bounds that we're
told to achieve are build
in constant expected time,
get and set_at in
constant expected time,
insert and delete_at in
linear expected time,
and insert and delete
first and last in--
we're running out of room here--
constant expected amortized.
OK.
So this is just what
we're told to do.
And now we start thinking.
So we're given this.
We want to build this.
And so I'm going to tell you
a little bit about my thought
process.
When I'm presented with
a problem like this,
the first thing is
to read the problem
and see, OK, what's
the hard part here?
What are the challenges?
So clearly, we
have to do all four
of these types of operations.
Build in linear expected time--
that's basically everything
we've seen.
Get or set_at in constant
expected time-- that's fast.
And that feels kind of
like this find operation.
So both of these seem
pretty matchy-matchy.
So that looks like
a good mapping.
I'm going to try to build
these operations using
those operations.
Insert and delete at
a specific location
in constant expected time--
sorry, linear expected
time-- that's big.
Linear expected time means I
can rebuild the entire data
structure every time
I do an operation.
So this is easy.
OK, that's the first
thing to realize.
This is big.
Great.
So I don't really have to
worry about these operations.
I mean, I do have
to implement them.
But it's not hard to do it that
fast, because I can rebuild.
And then here, insert and delete
at the beginning and the end
of the array, these are the DEQ,
Double-Ended Queue operations,
insert and delete at
either end, in constant
expected amortized time.
This, I feel like,
is a tricky one.
You've seen one way to
do this in a problem set.
But now we're going to
see another way with--
OK, the other thing to notice
is these "expected" words.
In this case, we're
told to use hashing.
But with lot of the problems,
you're not told how to solve it
or what you should be
basing your thing on.
And so "expected" is
always a good keyword,
because it means randomization
is involved somehow.
If you're told the bound
is going to be expected,
you probably need to
use randomization.
And in this class, the only form
of randomization you will use
is essentially hashing.
So that's a good hint.
In this case, we know what
we're supposed to use hashing.
All right, so this is
going to be the challenge.
But any ideas on how we
might tackle this problem?
How can we-- so set, remember,
every item has a key.
In a sequence, items
are just items.
And we're told to
insert and delete them
at particular locations.
But they don't have keys.
So one of the
challenges is going
to be to take our items
here, give them keys
so that we can
store them in a set.
Otherwise, we can't use find.
If there's no keys
there, there's
no way to search by key.
Ideas?
So let's think about
what we want to do.
Let's start with-- so
build, I think, is fine.
If you just want to
build a data structure,
you don't need to do anything.
The hard part are the
queries or updates
you want to be able to do
on your data structure.
Let's start with this
operation, get and set_at.
So remember, get_at,
you're given an index i,
and you want to find
the item at position i.
And set_at, we're
given a position,
and we want to change the
item stored at that position,
at that index, i.
Now, over here,
what we're given,
we can insert and delete.
But the main sort of lookup--
let's think about get_at first.
A natural mapping, given
this arrow, is find.
Find will search
for an item by key.
So here's-- just
staring at that,
let's look at all the possible
pairings you could do.
We have find by key over here.
And we need to implement
get_at by index.
So let's make the indices keys.
OK, so this is idea number one--
index-- assign a
key to each item
equal to index in sequence.
OK, so then, when I do--
to implement get_at,
I can just call
find of i if i is also a key.
And that should give me
the thing that I want.
Maybe for this to
make sense, let
me tell you how I'm building.
So if I'm given, say, an array
A of items, and they're both--
the only name conflict
here is build.
So let me call this
one sequence build.
And I'm going to implement
it using set build.
And I'll use some
shorthand notation here.
Let's say I want to
make an object that
has a key equal to i and
a value equal to A of i--
that's my object notation--
for i equals 0, 1, up
to size of A minus 1.
That's a little bit code-like,
but not quite literal code.
So I'm just going
to use this to say,
let's make an object
that has two parts.
One is called the key.
So we can talk about the
object.key, so we can--
which sets want to do.
And we're also going to store a
value, which is the actual item
that we're given.
So I'm just-- because these
are given in the sequence,
I'm just representing
that sequence order
by assigning i to be the key.
And so now, if I want to
find the item at index i,
I can do find of i.
And technically, I should
probably do .value.
That will give me
the actual item
that's stored at that position.
When I do find of i, I'm
going to get this whole object
with the key of i.
And then I want to get
the value part of it.
So then set_at, I
can just use this
find operation to get the
object and set its value to x.
Boom.
We've implemented array-like
semantics, get_at i
and set_at i, using a set.
If you've ever
programmed in JavaScript,
this should feel very familiar,
because JavaScript actually
implements arrays, at least
at the conceptual level,
as just general mapping
types, which are--
they call them objects, but
they are basically sets.
And it's even grosser.
They convert the integers
into strings and then
index everything by the
strings, semantically, anyway.
Implementation details
can be more efficient.
But conceptually,
that's what's going on.
And so that's the idea we're
doing here, which seems great.
Any problems?
So let's see.
There's insert_at and delete_at.
As I mentioned,
what I'm going to do
for those operations is just
rebuild the entire structure.
I'll just write that briefly.
Basically, let's just
iterate all the items.
Iterate all items, let's
say, into an array.
Insert, delete one of them.
And then rebuild.
OK, and if I was
writing a P set answer,
I would say a little
bit more detail
what I mean in this step.
I've done it in the notes.
Not that hard.
But we can afford
linear expected time.
I can afford to
call build again.
I guess, technically,
I'm calling
this build, sequence build.
So I can afford just to
extract things into an array,
do the linear time
operation on the array
with the shifting
and everything,
and then just call build again.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: I had a
question about get_at.
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] get_at.
ERIK DEMAINE: Sorry, no.
These are separate
definitions, yeah?
Sorry, they got a little close.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
ERIK DEMAINE: So this is
the definition of get_at.
This is the definition
of sequence build.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah.
Thanks for asking.
OK, all good, yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can you explain
the insert and delete again?
ERIK DEMAINE: Explain
insert and delete.
OK, so maybe I should actually
write one of them down,
or I'll just draw
a picture, maybe.
So we have this data structure,
which is now a sequence data
structure, represents
some sequence of items.
And my goal is to say,
delete the i-th item.
So there's some items in
here, x0 up to xn minus 1.
I want to remove xi
from the sequence.
Or I guess I should
draw it this way.
It's coming out.
So what I'm going to do is
first extract all the items
from the sequence.
And I didn't write
it, but there's
an interface over here called
iter, which just gives me
all the items in order.
So I'm going to extract
this into an array sequence.
Let's say I'll just build
a static array of size n.
I also have a length
operation that tells me
how many items are in here.
And the iter operation will
give me all the items in order.
And so I'll put into my
array x0 and then x1,
and so on, as they come out.
Then I go to position i.
And I want to delete that item
and shift all the others over.
This is the boring--
I think we even said how to
do delete_at in dynamic arrays
in recitation 2, pretty sure.
So I'm just mimicking that.
I'm building this just to
get the new order of things.
And then I'm applying,
via the build operation,
I'm building a
totally new sequence.
And that's how I would
implement delete_at, one way.
There are other ways.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do you have
[INAUDIBLE] space [INAUDIBLE],,
or--
ERIK DEMAINE: How much
space is this using?
Oh, problem with space
if you're inserting--
if you're inserting,
you probably
want to allocate a static
array of size n plus 1.
You know exactly
what's going to happen.
So just allocate a
little bit bigger.
Then you can do the shift.
You could also use
dynamic arrays.
But then you would
get maybe an--
it's not an amortized
bound, because you're only
doing one insertion.
The point is this
is really easy.
We can spend linear time.
So we can rebuild the--
we can rebuild this array
three times if we wanted.
Question?
AUDIENCE: What if
you weren't allowed
external non-constant space?
ERIK DEMAINE: Huh.
You're going to throw
me and open problem.
What if you only have
constant extra space?
Right.
Then I think we need to
use insert and delete.
So we could-- good question.
We could conceptually
do this shifting,
but do it using
insert and delete.
So we can-- so let's do
the delete case again.
So we want to--
here's xi.
We want to replace it
with xi plus 1 and so on.
And so we can start out by
deleting the item with key i.
That will get rid of this guy.
Then we can delete the
item with key i plus 1.
And that gives us the item.
And then we can reassign its
key to i instead of i plus 1
and then reinsert it.
So we can take this item out.
It has a key, which is--
I'll draw this properly.
So we have key i
plus 1 and value xi
plus 1 stored in
this data structure.
Then we update the key to i.
And then we reinsert it.
And it takes the
place of this guy.
So you could do that.
You could go down this
list and-- or not the list,
but you could iterate
for i equals-- sorry,
for j equals i to n minus 1,
and for each of those items,
delete it, change its key,
reinsert it with the new key.
And then you don't have to
build this intermediate data
structure.
So if you're told to
minimize space, great.
And maybe you think
of that as simpler.
I like to think of this
as simpler, because I--
point is, I have linear time.
I can do crazy, silly, very
non-data-structures-y things,
where I just start from scratch.
OK, great.
But there's one more
set of operations,
insert, delete, first and last.
Are these easy?
Good?
Shall we try?
We can insert last.
So this is given an item,
x, we want to add it
to the end of the structure.
So that means its index is going
to be equal to-- because we
start at 0, it's going to
be equal to the length,
current length of the structure.
So let's just insert
a new object, which
has key equal to the length.
And it has value equal to x.
We're done.
Delete last, similar.
Just delete the item
with key length minus 1.
OK, what about first?
This is supposed to add x to
the beginning of my sequence.
Well, now I realize
I have a problem,
because I want this
new item to have key 0,
because after I do an
insert first, get_at of 0
should return this item.
But I already have an item with
key 0, and an item with key 1,
and an item with key 2,
and so on down the way.
And so if I wanted
to give x a key of 0,
I have to shift the keys
of all of those items,
just like we were doing here.
And that's going to
take linear time.
But we were supposed to do this
in constant expected amortized
time.
So that's no good.
So this idea is not enough.
It's not a bad idea.
It's still a good idea.
But it's no longer what
we actually want to do.
It's only morally
what we want to do.
So do you have any thoughts
on how we might get around
this problem?
Seems like inserting
at position 0,
I need to shift everything
down, linear time.
That really sucks.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You could create some
sort of link to something else.
ERIK DEMAINE: Link this data
structure with another one.
So we could build
more than one set.
That's certainly allowed.
I don't know how
to do-- oh, I see.
You're saying maybe build
a whole other structure
for the items that
come before 0?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah, actually.
That would work, I think, maybe.
It's like in the P set.
Then you have to deal
with when-- if you delete
one of them, it becomes empty.
Then things get messy.
Delete first is also going
to be a problem, because I
delete beginning of
this data structure,
then I lose my 0 item.
And I want the new 0
item to be the 1 item.
And again, all
the indices shift.
So delete and inserting
at the first is hard.
So we could do that trick
like in the P set, but--
or like in the last
problem session and so on.
But there's a much simpler idea.
AUDIENCE: Can you
have an extra variable
to keep track of where
is the beginning?
ERIK DEMAINE: Nice.
I can have an extra
variable to keep track
of where the beginning is.
Call this first.
This is going to be the key
of the first item, index 0.
Another way to say
this is, let's just
use negative integers, right?
Sets work for any
keys, any integer keys.
OK, actually, we
technically said,
make sure you use
keys 0 to u minus 1.
But then, if you have negative
numbers, you can easily fold--
AUDIENCE: Wait, doesn't
it [INAUDIBLE] to like
[INAUDIBLE]?
ERIK DEMAINE: Ah.
Python negative numbers
mean something else.
But we're not using
a Python interface.
We're using our custom
magical set interface,
which we show how to implement
in recitation notes, which
can take an arbitrary key.
It hashes that key and finds
a place to put that item.
So we're not actually
storing things in order here.
We're storing things
in a hash table.
But we're not supposed to
get into the implementation
details.
I think the way we presented
hashing with our universal hash
functions, we only
allowed positive numbers.
So maybe, technically,
I should point out,
if you have positive
and negative numbers,
you can fold this in half by
mapping 0 to 0, 1 to 2, 2 to 4,
spreading it out.
And then you can take
minus 1 and map it
to plus 1, and minus 2
and map it to plus 3.
So this is like multiplying
each of these guys by 2,
and multiplying each of these
guys by minus 2 and adding 1.
And then you get non-negative
integers out of all integers.
This is a typical
math trick for showing
that the number of integers
is equal to the number
of non-negative integers,
which may seem weird to you.
But they're both
countably infinite.
So you could-- if your
structure only supports
non-negative keys, you could
map negative keys in this way
and throw them into
the hash table, OK?
So now, I allow
negative things for--
like that.
And so, great.
If I want to insert at the
beginning, what I can do
is just decrement my
first variable, which
is keeping track of the index.
So initially, first
is going to be 0.
So I'm going to
add into my build.
First, I'm going
to say first equals
0, because I start with
key 0 when I initially
build a structure.
And if I want to-- if I
need more room before 0,
I just set first to minus 1.
And if I already have
a minus 1 element,
I'll decrement it to minus 2.
Decrement means decrease by 1--
shows my assembly
language programming.
This is usually a built-in
operation on most computers.
And then I can insert an item
with key first and value x.
Great.
And if I want to
delete the first item,
I would delete the item with key
first and then increment first.
And now all of my operations
have to change a little bit--
let me use another color--
because I was
implicitly assuming here
that all my indices
started at i.
But now they start at first.
The index 0 maps to key first.
And so the right
thing to do here
is plus first and plus first.
Basically, add a whole bunch
of plus firsts throughout.
This one is probably fine.
If I'm globally rebuilding,
I can reassign all my labels.
But this one should
be first plus length.
OK, so just by keeping track
of where my keys are starting,
I can do this shifting and
not have to worry about stuff.
And this is a lot easier
than having to worry about
maintaining two structures, and
keeping them both non-empty,
and stuff like
that, because of--
if I assume my
mindset has this power
of dealing with negative
integers, and strings,
and whatever else.
Cool?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is there a
reason why you didn't do
like the sorting--
like, have [INAUDIBLE]?
ERIK DEMAINE: Oh, why
didn't I use a linked list?
Because this.
Linked lists are very bad at
get and set at a given index.
AUDIENCE: Is that the--
the bottom idea, is
that a linked list?
ERIK DEMAINE: This
is not a linked list.
This is just storing
a single number
as integer in your data
structure that says,
what is the smallest key
in my data structure?
That's all it this.
It's a counter.
AUDIENCE: Ah.
ERIK DEMAINE: OK,
so data structure
keeps track of its length.
And it keeps track
of the minimum key.
And so it will always
consist-- the invariant is,
you will always
have keys from first
up to first plus length minus 1.
And that's what we're
exploiting here.
We have no idea
where first will be.
It depends how many
operations you've done,
how many inserts at the
beginning, and so on.
But the keys-- keys will
always be first to first plus
length minus 1.
This is what we
call an invariant.
Useful to write
these things down so
you can understand
what the heck--
why is your data
structure correct?
Because of invariants
like this, which
you can prove by
induction, by showing,
each time you do
an operation, this
is maintained, even when
I'm changing first in order
to maintain this invariant.
Cool.
Sometimes you come up
with the invariant first.
In this case, I came up with
it post facto, after the fact.
Cool.
Let's move on to problem 3,
which is called critter sort.
And the other key thing I
want you to learn about--
question?
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So when you do
first, first plus 1,
is that a rebuilding
of the [INAUDIBLE]??
ERIK DEMAINE: This
is just a sentence.
It is not an algorithm
or data structure.
This is a mathematical property.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: This
is not an assignment.
This is a mathematically
is equal to.
AUDIENCE: But you are
re-indexing it though,
because you're
doing first plus 1.
ERIK DEMAINE: So are you asking
about one of these operations,
like this one?
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
Never mind.
I get it.
OK.
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah.
So the other
important takeaway I
want you to get about
reading our problem sets
is that they have
hidden humor inside.
I don't know if you've noticed.
But here's an example of a
problem called critter sort.
Ashley Gettem collects
and trains pocket critters
to fight other pocket
critters in battle.
What is this a reference to?
AUDIENCE: Digimon.
ERIK DEMAINE: Digimon.
Wow, you guys are so young.
Pokemon, the ancient form.
Pokemon is short
for pocket monsters.
And in fact, in the original--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: --anime--
AUDIENCE: Actually,
there's [INAUDIBLE]..
ERIK DEMAINE: I don't know.
This is all after my time.
We can debate after.
So pocket critters
is a reference
to pocket monsters,
which is Pokemon.
Who's Ashley Gettem?
AUDIENCE: Ash.
ERIK DEMAINE: Ash
Ketchum is his full name
in the English version.
Totally different name
in the Japanese version.
But they're both puns on
collect them all, right?
All right, so that's
the important stuff.
We'll see more jokes later.
So there's this setup.
But basically, we
have n critters.
And we want to sort them
by four different things.
And so I'm just going
to abstract this problem
to sort n objects by the
following types of keys.
And for each one, we want to
know what the best sorting
algorithm is.
And there's this footnote
that's very important that says,
faster correct algorithms
will receive more points
than slower correct algorithms.
Also, correct algorithms
will receive more points
than incorrect algorithms.
But that's implicit.
Incorrect generally gets zero.
OK, so part a, it
says, species ID.
But basically, we have integers
and the range minus n to n.
So if I want to sort n integers
in the range minus n to n,
what should I do?
This is a reference to
yesterday's lecture.
Yeah?
Radix sort, yeah.
Always a good answer.
Or almost always a good
answer when you have integers.
It's a good answer whenever
you have small integers.
Now, radix sort, the
way we phrased it--
let me maybe put it down here.
Radix sort sorts n integers in
the range 0 to u minus 1 in n
plus n log base n of u time.
And in particular,
this is linear time
if u is n to some
constant power.
OK, so can I just apply this
as is to these integers?
No, because they're negative.
So what should I do?
Maybe I should do
my folding trick.
We just saw how to take negative
numbers and fold them in,
interspersed with
positive numbers.
If I sort that, will that work?
No, because that does
not preserve order.
It would intersperse.
We want all the negative
numbers to come before all
the positive numbers.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can you just
add n to all the integers?
ERIK DEMAINE: Just add n, yep.
Boom.
Plus n.
Now we have integers
in the range--
let's be careful--
0 to 2n.
Cool.
Now we can apply this.
Now u equals,
technically, 2n plus 1,
because we're only supposed
to go to u minus 1.
But that's fine.
That's linear.
And so we can sort
in linear time, easy.
This is a super easy problem.
But in each one, we might need
to do some transformation.
Part b is a little
more interesting.
So we have strings over 26
letters of length at most
10 ceiling log n.
OK, this is a little trickier.
What could I do?
Again, I'd like to see
whether radix sort applies.
I should say radix sort sorts.
I'd like to see if
radix sort applies.
To do that, I have to map these
strings into integers somehow.
Any way to do that?
This is easy if you
understand radix sort.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can you just
index the letters?
ERIK DEMAINE:
Index, the letters.
Yeah.
Yeah, we can map--
right.
So we can map A to 0, B to 1.
Then what?
AUDIENCE: Oh, wait.
Length--
ERIK DEMAINE: So
that's for each letter.
But we have a lot of letters.
There are only 26 letters.
But then we have 10 log
n letters in a string.
That is, together, a single
key that we need to sort.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can't we just sort by
the first letter first, then--
ERIK DEMAINE: Sort by the first
letter, then the second letter.
That is exactly the
opposite of radix sort.
Remember, radix sort,
we want to start
by the last letter, and then
the next to last letter,
and finally, the first letter.
AUDIENCE: But you want
to sort by the first one
in order to alphabetize things.
ERIK DEMAINE: No,
to alphabetize--
we do want to, in the end,
sort by the first letter.
But that's at the end.
So at the end--
remember, radix sort
always goes backwards
from the least significant
to the most significant.
And so indeed, that
is what we want to do.
You're just saying,
use radix sort.
But what am I radix sort on?
What am I radix sorting on?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, on the last
letters, not the first letters.
ERIK DEMAINE: So
technically, that
would be using counting
sort on the last letter,
counting sort of the
next to last letter, dot,
dot, dot, counting sort
on the first letter.
But that is, together,
radix sort on something,
or Jason likes to call
this tuple sorting.
Tuple sort is the thing--
is the algorithm that says,
sort by the last thing,
then sort by the previous
thing, and so on.
You can also think of
this as radix sorting
on a number written in base 26.
They're the same thing.
But in the end, we can
sort in linear time.
AUDIENCE: How do you
ensure that the letters are
sorted in order, though?
Like, how do you ensure that--
how do you tell the algorithm
that you want A to come--
just like not-- 0 is less
than 1, A is less than B.
ERIK DEMAINE: Right.
So I mean, technically,
when you call
something like tuple sort--
or maybe it's even clearer
when you call radix sort.
Radix sort, you're giving
it a bunch of numbers.
So you're taking these strings
and mapping them to numbers.
And when you do that, you
get to decide which letter
is the most
significant, which is
the least significant, right?
So you will choose to always map
the first letter in your string
to position--
to value, or the--
what do you call it?
Position in positional notation.
Position 26 to the power 10
log n as the most significant.
So it's always the
most significant.
Even if your string
is of length 1,
you want to put that in
the most significant digit.
And you'll pad with
zeros at the end
if you run out of
letters in your string.
AUDIENCE: How many times are
you running counting sort here?
ERIK DEMAINE: How many times
am I running counting sort?
Oh, 10 log n times.
Whoops.
Yeah, good question.
Good point.
Yeah, I computed this wrong.
So right.
There are log n
digits in the string.
So that is bad.
I mean, it's OK.
We'll end up with n log n
running time by the tuple sort.
However-- so that's
the tuple sort.
So I should really make
this not equivalent.
If I run tuple short letter
by letter, I'm going to do--
I'm running counting
sort log n times.
And so I get n log n, because
each one takes linear time.
If I map my strings
into numbers first,
radix sort doesn't use base 26.
It uses base n.
And then it will
only run 10 times,
because 2 to the 10
log n is n to the 10.
And so the numbers that we're
sorting are between 0 and n
to the 10.
And so u is n to the 10.
And so that's the case when
radix sort runs in linear time.
So if you run tuple short
letter by letter, it's slow.
If you run radix sort,
it's doing a whole bunch
of letters at once.
Effectively, it's
doing log n letters
at a time in a single
call to counting sort.
And so the radix sort will
actually win and get linear.
There's a subtlety
here, which is,
I'm assuming that we can
actually take these strings
and convert them into integers
in constant time each.
And this problem
set was ambiguous.
And both answers were accepted.
If you assume these letters
are nice and compactly
stored, and they
fit in 10 words,
because a word is at
least log n bits long,
then you can actually do this.
If you store each letter
in a separate word,
then just reading the entire
input will take n log n time.
So that's a subtlety which we
don't need to worry too much
about in this class.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
bounding the letters
to numbers.
And like, how would that help?
Because we still have to do 26--
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah, there
are 26 possible letters,
numbering them 0 to 25.
And then when we take
a string, like AA,
we map this into 00 in base 26.
That's a number.
If we do BB, for
example, this maps to 11
in base 26, which means 1
times 26 plus 1, which is 27.
OK, so that's the
mapping that I mean.
AUDIENCE: You're mapping the
whole string [INAUDIBLE]??
ERIK DEMAINE: The whole string
to a single number, yeah.
And there's a subtlety,
because I want lexicographic.
I need to pad things
with spaces at the end
or pad them with As
at the end in case
they're shorter than 10 log n.
OK, cool.
That was b.
c is not very interesting.
It's integers in the
range 0 to n squared.
This, I can just
solve with radix sort,
because my radix
sort, at this point,
we've done it a third time.
Radix sort, we can sort as
long as the integers are
bounded by a polynomial.
Here, it's a fixed polynomial
with a constant exponent.
So this will-- and
this is radix sort,
like we saw, that just
calls counting sort twice,
linear time.
d is where things
get more interesting.
Let me get this
phrasing the same.
So in d, we have rational
numbers of the form w over f.
This is some win ratio.
Always in the range 0 to 1.
So we saw w is at most f.
And 0 is less than w, is
less than f, is less than n
squared, because the--
that is really confusing--
is less than n squared--
those are separate statements--
because the f actually
comes from part c.
And c is really a
setup for this one.
Doesn't really matter
what this means.
It's just that we
have numbers w and f,
where w is always less than f.
And they're between
0 and n squared.
So you should think, this is
a good range for me, right?
That I'm representing
this rational
in terms of two numbers
between 0 and n squared.
So there's like n to
the 4th possible choices
for what w and f are.
So the range of my
values is n to the 4th.
That's the setting where
radix sort should run fast.
Unfortunately, these numbers--
what I want to sort by
is not an integer.
It's a rational.
And that's annoying.
So there are a couple of
ways to solve this problem.
In general, a good way to solve
sorting is to use merge sort.
Merge sort is always
a good answer.
It's not the best answer.
In these cases, we
shaved off a log.
We got to linear time.
But n log n is pretty good.
It's pretty close to n.
So first goal might
be, can we even achieve
n log n via merge sort?
What would I need to do in order
to actually apply merge sort
to this instance?
What does merge
sort do to its keys?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Isolate
and compare them.
ERIK DEMAINE: It isolates and
compares them, yeah, right.
So there's an array
data structure.
And it indexes into the array.
That's the isolation.
But then the thing it actually
does with the items themselves
is always a comparison.
And this is why we introduced
the comparison model
and proved an n log n lower
bound in the comparison model,
because merge sort,
and insertion sort,
and selection sort are
all comparison algorithms.
Radix sort is not.
But this one is.
But to apply merge sort, I need
to say, how do I compare wi
over fi versus wj over fj?
My computer only
deals with integers.
We can't actually
represent wi over fi
explicitly in binary, because
it has infinitely many bits.
But I can represent
it implicitly
by storing wi and fi.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Multiply by fi and fj.
ERIK DEMAINE: Multiply
by fi and fj, yeah.
When I went-- I
didn't go to school,
but then we learned
cross multiplication,
which is the same as
multiplying both sides by fi
and multiplying both
sides by fj, as you said.
So then we get fi fj less
than question mark f--
whatever-- fi wj.
When we do that, we better
make sure that the things
we're multiplying
by are non-negative.
Otherwise, the sign flips.
But here, we assume
they're all non-negative.
So this is good.
And now we're just
multiplying two integers here,
multiplying two integers
here, and comparing.
Those are all things I
can do in a word RAM.
So this was actually
the intended solution
when this problem was posed.
Here's a way to do
comparison sort.
We get n log n.
But in fact, you can
achieve linear time.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] that
solution, how would you
quickly say which one's bigger?
Because wi times f
of j, one of them
belongs to one of the
Pokemons, and the other one
is [INAUDIBLE].
ERIK DEMAINE: I feel like
there's a joke here, like--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE:
Pikachu is superior.
That's always the answer.
So how do I tell
whether one Pokemon
is superior to the other?
If I multiply my--
I multiply i's f value
with j's w value.
And I see whether that's
greater than i's w
value times j's f value.
And if it is--
so these are equivalent.
If this one is
greater than this one,
I know that this is
greater than this.
These are equivalent sentences
by mathematics, by algebra.
And so this is what
I want to know.
This would say j
is superior to i.
And so I determine that
by actually doing this.
So then I don't have to divide
and deal with real numbers,
because I don't know how,
because I'm a computer.
We're all computers in the end.
OK.
So it would be great
if my numbers all
had the same denominator.
If they all had the same f, then
I could just compare the w's.
So that's one intuition
for why we can actually
do this in linear time.
But the way I like to
think about it-- so let's
just draw the real
interval from 0 to 1.
And there are various spots
all over here that represent--
I can't actually compute this.
But conceptually, each of
these wi fi's falls somewhere
in that interval from 0 to 1.
And I want to sort them somehow.
So one thing that
would be great is
if I could take
these real numbers
and somehow map
them to integers,
which are uniformly spaced,
maybe a few more of them.
But these go from
0 to u minus 1.
And if I could get
u relatively small,
and I could map each of these--
so I want that mapping
to be order preserving.
And I want two very close,
but distinct items to map to--
distinct keys here.
I want them to map to
distinct integers down here.
If I could do that, then I
just sort by the integers.
And that's the same as
sorting by the real numbers.
And so at this point,
I wonder, how close
can two of these numbers be?
So how close can two keys be?
So I want to consider wi
over fi minus wj over fj
in absolute value.
Now I do algebra.
So this is--
I'd like to bring
this into one ratio.
So this is--
I can do that by multiplying
1 by fi, 1 by fj.
Now that's wi fj minus
wj fi, which should
look a lot like something here.
But never mind.
I'm sure there's a
deep connection here.
I can probably use this to
prove that and vice versa.
Cool.
So with some absolute
values, same thing.
Maybe these are non-negative,
so I can actually
just put absolute
values on the top part.
And OK, wi is an integer, fj is
an integer, wj is an integer,
fi is an integer, all
greater than or equal to 0.
So this thing is an integer.
So it could be equal to 0.
It's a non-negative integer,
because all the things
are non-negative.
It could be equal to 0.
But if they're
equal to 0, that's
actually identical
ratios, right?
If this is 0, the
whole thing is 0.
And so these two
values were the same.
OK, but let's
suppose it's not 0.
If it's not 0, it's
actually at least 1,
the absolute value,
because it's an integer.
What about the bottom?
fi-- so now we want this--
I want to know how
small this ratio can be.
It's going to be small when
this is small and this is big.
How big could fi fj be?
Well, we're told that all the
f's are less than n squared.
So this thing is
at most n squared,
n to the 4th, less
than n the 4th--
n squared minus 1 squared,
less than n to the 4th.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: fi is
at most n squared.
fj is at most n squared.
So it's n squared squared.
So this is at least
1 over n to the 4th.
So the closest the two
points can get here
is 1 over n to the 4th.
So what can I do to scale
that up to make them
kind of like integers?
Multiply by n to the 4th.
So just multiply by n to
the 4th and then floor.
So we're going to
take each fi over--
I'd like to compute this ratio.
But I don't know how.
So instead, I'm going
to take fi, multiply--
OK.
Conceptually, what I want to
do is multiply by n to the 4th
and take the floor.
How do I actually do this
in a machine that doesn't
have real numbers like this?
So I don't have a
floor operation.
I just have integer operations.
Then I can take fi,
multiply it by n to the 4th,
and integer divide by wj.
That is the same--
that computes exactly
this, because I
can do the multiplication
and the division
in either order in real space.
And then this does the floor
at the appropriate time.
But this is just
operations on integers.
And now these are
integers representing
how good my Pokemon are.
They have the property that
any two distinct ones--
before I take the floor, any
two distinct ones are at least 1
apart.
So after I take the floor,
they will remain 1 apart.
They will remain
distinct integers.
And so I have successfully
mapped my real numbers
to integers where distinct
real numbers match
distinct integers.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Wait.
So why is fi now in
the numerator, and wi
in the denominator?
ERIK DEMAINE: Did I flip them?
Yeah, sorry.
Please invert
everything-- just here.
This is w and fi.
That was just a typo.
That's all of them.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Are they
both i's or j's?
ERIK DEMAINE: These are
supposed to both be i's, yeah.
Thank you.
This was for each
Pokemon, i, we're
going to compute
this as our key.
And then we're going to
sort by those integer keys.
And that will sort the
Pokemon by their ratios.
Let's write mon for monster.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
u minus 1 [INAUDIBLE]??
ERIK DEMAINE: So u was just a--
sorry, this is-- a label on
this thing might help you.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah.
So now my u-- oh, right.
What is my u?
What is my largest key?
It occurs to me, I really would
like fi to be bigger than 0.
But let's not worry about it.
How big can u be?
Well, the biggest this
can be is if fi is small,
and this is big.
Let's say fi can
only go down to 1.
Otherwise, we'll
get a division by 0.
We have to deal with
infinity especially.
Probably, the problem isn't
even well defined then.
How big could this be?
Well, I know the wi's--
AUDIENCE: f's are
defined as positive.
ERIK DEMAINE: Oh, good.
Thank you.
So there's also a
positive constraint here.
Just I failed to preserve
that constraint in my mapping
from the word problem
into the formal problem.
So f is the least 1.
Good.
But worst case is when it's 1.
And when wi-- how
big could it be?
Well, n squared minus 1.
So this could be,
basically, n squared
times n to the 4th divided
by 1, which is n to the 6th.
So w-- or sorry, u, the
largest key I can have plus 1,
is n to the 6th.
But that's OK, because
radix sort can handle
any fixed polynomial in n.
So it's going to end up doing
six counting sort passes.
OK, that's problem 3.
Let's move on to problem 4.
So problem 4, MIT has
employed Gank Frehry.
Who's that?
Frank Gehry, yeah.
This is a common encoding
that Jason really likes.
I've grown to like it.
This is called spoonerism,
where you replace some part
of the beginning of your thing.
OK, that's one joke.
There's another joke
in this problem.
Anyway, they're building a
new wing of the Stata Center,
as one does.
We have a bunch of cubes.
If you read long enough, you
realize that's a red herring.
Cubes do not play a
role in this problem.
In the end, what
we have is a bunch
of integers, which happen to be
the side length of the cubes.
But we just care about
the side lengths, not
their volume or anything--
s n minus 1.
And we want two numbers
in s summing to h.
AUDIENCE: This is
dumb, but how can cubes
have more than six sides?
ERIK DEMAINE: This
is a side length, not
the number of sides.
So a cube--
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
ERIK DEMAINE: Cool.
I didn't know we'd be
doing 3D geometry today.
That's si.
OK, so you got little cubes.
You've got big cubes.
This is a small si.
This is a big si.
Doesn't matter, though.
They're just numbers.
We're not using them at all.
In the problem,
you're trying to like
stack one cube on the other.
But all we really care
about is two numbers
whose sum, regular old
sum, is exactly h, ideally.
There's going to be two
versions of this problem.
And so the first goal
is to solve this exactly
in linear expected time.
That's what the problem says.
So what do we know?
Well, linear time, that's--
can't get much faster than
that, because we need that just
to read the input.
Expected time-- hashing, right?
We're told, basically,
we should use hashing.
Now, if we're really
annoying, maybe we
throw that in even
when you don't need it.
But that's pretty rare.
So when we see expected,
we should, in a problem
set setting like
this-- in real life,
you never know what
you should use.
But in our-- with your
learning in this class,
we're going to tell
you basically what
tricks you're allowed to use.
Here, you're allowed
to use randomization.
So probably, we need it.
Indeed, you need it
to achieve this bound.
Cool.
Hashing.
Not obvious how to approach
this problem with hashing.
So I'm going to
give you the way I--
it's hard for me to not
know this algorithm.
But to me, the first thing
you should think about
is if I have linear
time and n things,
and I'm going to use hashing,
the obvious thing to do
is to take those n things
and put them in a hash table.
Build.
Why not?
So let's just build a hash
table on all the keys in s.
That's idea one.
Seems like the
first thing to try.
So what does that let me do?
It lets me--
I just erased the
interface for hash tables.
But I can build a
sequence out of it.
But normally, it gives
me a set interface.
So I can call find
now in constant time.
It lets me, given the
number, determine immediately
whether that number is in s.
Well, that sounds
interesting, because I'm
looking for two numbers in s.
So it lets me find one of them.
So I call it twice?
No.
Calling it twice and only
spending constant time
on this beautiful data
structure will not
give you anything useful.
But we have linear time, right?
So in addition to
building a table,
we could call find on
that table a linear number
of times, because each find
only takes constant expected
amortized time.
So if I do n of them, that
will take linear expected time.
The amortization disappears,
because I'm using it n times.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: Oh, right.
Find never has amortization.
So it doesn't disappear,
because it was never there.
Never mind.
I can afford n calls,
or 5n calls, to find,
because each one costs
constant expected.
And the total for that
will be linear time.
So the next idea is let's
just somehow call find
a linear number of times, OK?
So I want to find two numbers
summing to a given value, h.
That wasn't maybe
clear, but h is given.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
How long does it take
to build the hash table?
ERIK DEMAINE: How long does
it take to build a hash table?
It was previously on this
board-- linear expected time.
See previous lecture.
No, two years ago.
OK.
Well, if we're going to do
this a linear number of times,
I guess we should
have a for loop.
Let's do a for loop
over the numbers.
That's the next idea.
Loop over s.
And at this point,
we're done, almost.
I want space.
So I want to loop
over the numbers.
And each one, I
want to do a find.
That's kind of all
I have time to do.
So seems like a
natural thing to try.
This is by no means easy.
Don't get me wrong.
Having these ideas is--
while I'm explaining them
as the obvious ideas,
they're not obvious.
But they are easy,
at least, just not
obvious to come up
with the easy ideas.
So let's loop over
s, somehow call find,
using our hash table.
So the order is actually, we're
going to build the hash table,
then loop.
And inside the loop, we're
going to call find once
per loop iteration.
So let's do it.
Let's say, for si in S--
so I want to find two numbers.
Here, I have exhaustively
looped over one number.
I just need to find
the second number that
can possibly add up, right?
I want to find whether
there's an sj in S such
that si plus sj equals h.
Can I do that query with find?
How?
So what does find do?
Find says, if I give you a key,
it will tell me whether-- like,
if I knew what sj
was, it would tell me
whether it's in S. Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can't you
just subtract h from si
and then see if [INAUDIBLE]?
ERIK DEMAINE: Subtract h from
si and see whether that exists.
Did get it right?
AUDIENCE: h minus si.
ERIK DEMAINE: h minus si.
I always get it wrong.
Don't feel bad that
you also got it wrong.
It makes me feel better,
because I always get it wrong.
So the claim is this.
Why?
Because what we
want to do is find--
well, OK.
Let's see what it
says over here.
So if we do h minus
si equals sj--
so these are
equivalent statements,
just by moving the si over.
And this is a query we can do.
So let's remember, these
are things we know.
And s.j is something
we don't know.
All that we know
is that it's an s.
OK, so we know these two things.
So if we bring them
over to the same side,
we're searching for
an unknown thing,
which is equal to exactly this
thing that we can compute.
So we just compute h minus si.
We call find.
That will tell us whether
there is an sj equal to this.
OK, so this is like a comment.
And this is what we actually do.
And if there is a pair
of numbers summing to h,
this will find it.
How much time did it take?
Well, we're doing n
iterations of this loop.
Each one, we're calling
a single find operation.
And find costs
constant expected time.
And so the total is
linear expected time.
Great.
Part A done.
Then they throw part b
at us, make it harder.
Those pesky instructors.
So we read part b.
Part b says two things
to make it harder.
So first of all, we want
linear worst-case time.
And furthermore-- so we
can't use hashing anymore.
Furthermore-- so
here, we just needed
to solve the exact problem
to find whether the two
numbers sum exactly to h.
Now we would like to find the
best solution smaller than
or equal to h.
So find biggest
pairwise sum that's
less than or equal to h if
there's no perfect pair.
But we're given a little bit
of extra information, which
is, we can assume h
equals 600 n to the 6th.
That's a weird polynomial.
Took me a while to even notice
that that was a joke in here--
6006, hiding in a polynomial.
All right, so polynomial.
Hm.
That should make you
think radix sort.
It is radix sort week.
So that is a natural
thing to try.
But in general, even
later in the semester,
when you see a nice
polynomial with a fixed
constant like this,
and it's somehow
related to the integers
we're dealing with,
you should think radix sort.
Especially because now, we
want constant worst-case time,
radix sort seems like
a good thing to do.
Don't know what
to do with it yet.
In fact, I can't even
apply radix sort.
But idea one is radix sort.
Just because I see
that polynomial,
I think maybe I should try it.
Now, there's a problem here,
because we're given some
numbers, some integers, si's.
We're also given h.
We're told now that is a
nice, small polynomial.
But we have no idea how
big these numbers are.
So the problem with
this idea is that--
but si could be bigger than h.
We have no idea how
big the si's are.
What can I say
about si's that are
bigger than h for this problem?
Summing to h.
Oh.
I didn't say it, but all these
numbers are non-negative.
That's important.
That looks like [INAUDIBLE].
Greater than or equal to 0.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
solution [INAUDIBLE]..
ERIK DEMAINE: Right.
If I'm finding a sum that's
less than or equal to h,
they're non-negative.
And any number that's greater
than h, I can just throw away.
They'll never be in a solution.
So they already-- a sum of
one number is bigger than h.
So two is only going to get
bigger if they're non-negative.
So idea number two is let's
just throw out all the big si's,
anything bigger than h.
Now, that won't change the
answer, because those can never
be in a solution.
And now I have all
the si's having
the property that they're
less than or equal to h.
And so they are small,
bounded by a fixed polynomial.
And now I can apply radix sort.
So after this idea, I
can apply this idea.
OK, this gives you
a flavor of how
I like to think about problems.
I see clues, like a polynomial.
I think radix sort doesn't work.
But with some more ideas,
I can get it to work.
OK.
What goes with the--
so now I've sorted si.
OK, great.
S is sorted.
I guess we can try to
do the same algorithm,
except I don't have
a hash table anymore.
So let's just try doing a
for loop over the S. Why not?
So let's do for si in
S. But now it's sorted.
So presumably, I should
exploit the sorted order.
So let's do them in order.
So i equals 0, 1,
up to n minus 1.
Let's say that s0
is the smallest.
s1 is the next smallest.
sn minus 1 is the biggest.
So I want to do something with--
so I have si.
And I want to figure out
whether h minus si is in there.
Hard to do that better than--
actually, I could do
this with binary search.
I'm looking for this value.
And I have a sorted array now.
So I could binary
search for h minus si.
And in log n time, I will find
whether that guy is in there.
And if not, keep looping.
I can keep track of the
best thing that I found.
And so in n log n time, I
can definitely solve this.
But I'd like to get linear time.
Do you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Well,
I'm just wondering,
how would you [INAUDIBLE]?
Like, why would you
[INAUDIBLE] whether that
is in there [INAUDIBLE]?
ERIK DEMAINE: I'm
not looking for si.
I'm going to compute h minus si.
So this is-- maybe I shouldn't
even write this down, but--
AUDIENCE: She's asking about
the [INAUDIBLE] constraint of,
we're not looking for h.
We're looking for
something smaller than h.
ERIK DEMAINE: This one?
Or--
AUDIENCE: Something larger.
ERIK DEMAINE: Oh, this thing.
AUDIENCE: A large
thing less than h.
ERIK DEMAINE: Right.
So in particular, if there
are two items that sum to h,
I want to find it.
So let's start with that.
So I'm binary searching
for h minus si in S.
So I could certainly do that.
And if I find it, great.
I found a pair that
sum to exactly h.
If I don't find it, binary
search tells me not only
that it's not there,
but it tells me
what the previous
and next value are.
So even though h
minus si isn't there,
I can get the next largest thing
and the next smallest thing.
What I want is the
next smallest thing.
And that will be the largest
sum I can get using si.
And so then that's one
candidate for a sum less than
or equal to h.
I want to find the largest one.
So I do a for loop.
I always keep track of--
I take a list of all
the candidates I got.
Each time I do an iteration of
this loop, I get one candidate.
Then I take the largest one.
OK, so return largest candidate.
So this gives me a candidate,
just the previous item.
This is what we called find
previous, or find prev,
probably, in our set interface.
And if you have a sorted set,
you can do that in log n time.
So this is an n log n solution,
because we do n iterations
through the loop.
Each binary search takes log n.
I want to get linear.
This is not obvious.
The best intuition I can
think of for this next idea
is, well, I start with the
very smallest item in S.
And I want to sum up to
something that's kind of big,
right?
I threw away all the
items bigger than h.
If s0 is like tiny,
like close to 0,
because it's the smallest
one, then maybe I
should look at the
end of the array,
because I want to
compare, or I want
to add the smallest
thing probably
with the biggest thing.
That's as close
as I can imagine.
So then-- so here's my sorted S.
It's the smallest item, biggest
item.
So I'm going to loop over
these items one by one.
So let's start by comparing the
first one with the last one.
The two-finger algorithm, OK?
This is the big idea.
You're doing it all
the time in this class.
It's super useful.
We saw it in merge sorts, for
example, and merging two lists.
We have fingers in two
lists that advance.
And because they only advance,
it takes linear total time.
So we're going to do this kind
of folded in backwards here.
We're going to start here.
This seems like a good
candidate to start with.
Now, what else
could this add with?
Well, maybe smaller items.
And maybe I have to go
all the way through here.
And then I've got to
advance my left finger.
Yeah, OK.
So here's the idea.
So let's look at--
so I'm going to call this
finger i and this finger j.
So we want to sum two things.
So I guess one other
inspiration here is,
we want to add two things up.
And we have one algorithm
that has the word "two" in it.
And it's the
two-finger algorithm.
So let's try that.
So we're going to
start at i equals 0
and j equals n minus 1.
We're going to look at si plus
sj and see, how good is it?
How close to summing to h is it?
Well, in particular, it's
either less than or equal to h
or bigger than h.
If it's bigger than h--
so this sum is too big.
I can't even use
it as a candidate.
Well, that means I really
don't need this guy, right?
It's too big overall.
I'm adding the smallest
item to this item.
And it's too big.
Well, then I should
go to the left.
I should move my right
finger to the left.
So in this case, we decrement j.
Move the right
finger to the left.
So I'm guessing, in this
case, I increment i.
Why?
If I add these two items
up, and this is too small,
it's smaller than h, then this
item was probably too small.
It might actually--
it's an OK solution.
It's less than or equal to h.
So I should keep
it as a candidate.
Let's say add candidate.
So I'm just going to keep a
list of candidates that I see.
So this is a possible solution.
It might not be the best one.
But it's one to add to my list.
And then I'm going to increase i
and now work on this sub-array,
because that will be
a little bit bigger.
I can't go this way
to make it bigger,
because I'm at the last item.
And it's not obvious
that this works.
I think there's a nice invariant
that will help somewhere.
Where'd I put my piece of paper?
Yeah.
So here's an invariant.
Oh, yes.
It's really clear this
is the right thing
to do in the first step.
And the tricky part is to argue
that it works in all steps,
because when I really have the
smallest item and the largest
item, it's clear that I should
advance one or the other
if I'm too small or too big.
But the way to prove it
in general by induction
is to show this invariant that--
so at some point
through this execution,
i and j are somewhere.
And I want to say that if I
take any j from the right--
any j prime to the right of
j and any i prime to the left
of i, unstrictly, then
all of those pairs,
all those pairwise sums,
are either too big--
and that's when we decrease j--
or they're less than or equal
to the largest candidate
that we've seen so far.
That's because we added
these candidates in there.
So that invariant will
hold by induction,
because whenever there's a
possible thing that's good,
I add it to my candidate list.
And then, at the end
of the algorithm,
I just loop through my
candidate list, compute the max,
return that pair.
OK, so that is
two-finger algorithm,
which solves the
non-exact problem
in linear worst-case time.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: i cannot
equal j, right?
ERIK DEMAINE: Oh,
i cannot-- right.
So what are the
termination conditions?
When i equals j, that's
probably when you want to stop.
It depends.
You could say, if i is
greater than j, stop.
Return max candidate.
There are two ways to
interpret this problem.
One is that the two
values you choose in S
need to be different
values, or you
allow them to be the same value,
like they can both be h over 2.
And either way is
easier to solve.
If you want to allow
s over 2, then I
would put greater than here.
If you don't want
to allow h over 2,
then I would put greater
than or equal to--
either way.
Both of these problems,
you can solve both ways.
Or both algorithms can
handle both situations.
OK, one more problem.
All right.
Yeah, I'm all out of time.
But I'm getting
faster and faster.
Of course, on the
hardest problem,
I can do it the fastest.
All right, so Meff Ja--
this is a reference to Jeff
Ma of the MIT Blackjack
Team, who I got to speak here
at LSC a bunch of years ago.
But he's featured in
the movie 21 and so on--
fictionalized.
So I was playing this game.
It's a great setup.
You should definitely
read this problem--
Po- k -er.
And he has a deck of
cards, where each card has
a letter of the alphabet on it.
I guess this is
the right way up.
So I, of course,
have such a deck.
Doesn't everyone?
You can buy these.
I have several, actually.
And so we can do a
quick magic trick,
like pick a card, any
card-- here, pick a card.
[INAUDIBLE] OK, good choice.
I can't force, so it
doesn't really matter.
OK, and so this is
your card, right?
And your card is an s, right?
OK, good.
No, not all the cards are s's.
[LAUGHTER]
But he has mirrors
in his glasses.
No.
I can reveal later
how that's done.
OK, so a deck of cards.
Each card has 26
possible letters on it.
And there's this
weird dealing process.
Even just defining
this problem is
going to take a little while.
Oh, here's my piece of paper.
So we have this dealing process.
Here's an example that's
in the program, abcdbc.
So you know the
order of the cards.
This is the top card.
This is the bottom card.
And now, randomly, you do a cut.
Cut is this.
So I take some chunk off the
top, move it to the bottom,
once, randomly.
So for example, I
could take this cut.
And then what I would get
is cdbc for this part that's
copied here, and ab as the--
so this is-- so the first
thing we do is cut at i.
This is position i.
In this example, i equals 2.
OK, then we deal
the top k cards.
So let's say we deal the
top four cards, k equals 4.
So this is deal k.
So we get cdbc, in that order.
But the order doesn't matter,
because the last operation
we do in the problem is
sort them, which is bccd,
like you do when you
get a hand of cards.
You tend to sort them.
OK, so this is a process.
Given a deck-- so the
deck here is fixed.
We call this process, I
think, P of D comma i comma k.
We're told what D is.
We're told what k is.
i is chosen randomly.
And we'd like to know what
happens with different i's.
So if you stare at this problem
enough, it begins to simplify.
So this is a complicated setup.
But what's really going on is
we're starting at position i.
And we're taking the next k
cards from there cyclically.
So here, we just
took those four.
If i equaled 3, we would deal
d, then b, then c, then a.
But then we sort them.
OK, so we're getting different
substrings of length k,
cyclically.
But then we're
sorting those letters.
Sorting is really
crucial for this problem
to at all be feasible.
It took me a while even to
see how to solve this problem.
But the key is sorting,
that they get sorted,
because that means--
because we sort, it
doesn't matter whether you
have aaba, or baaa, or abaa.
These are all the same.
If you take these
cards dealt, you
sort them to the
same thing, which is
the one I didn't write, aaab.
All of these get sorted
to the same thing.
So we lost some information
when we sort, lost the order.
The first question
to get you thinking
in this direction, part a,
says, build a data structure
given D and k that lets me know,
given two indices, i and j,
do I end up with
the exact same hand?
This thing is called a hand.
And it's exactly this P D, i, k.
So I want to do P D,
i, k and P, d, j, k.
And I want to know--
JK.
And I want to know whether
those two things are
equal in constant time.
That's what this says--
constant time.
Doesn't say worst case,
but worst case is possible.
And that sounds hard,
because, I mean,
there's k symbols for one
of them, another k symbols
for the other guy.
But we don't have to
compare the symbols.
We just need to compare the
sorting of those strings.
And this, we can compress.
So this is a subtlety.
But all I really need to know
is that there are three a's
here, and one b, and zero
c's, and zero d's, and zero
e's, and so on.
But because there's only
26 letters in this deck--
and indeed, in this deck, it
happens upper and lowercase a
through z.
But we might have n cards.
But there are only
26 possible labels.
So in fact, a lot
of them are going
to be equal if n is large.
So this is a good
compression scheme,
because to represent the things
I get after sorting, I just
need to give you 26 numbers.
And for us, 26 is small,
because 26 is a constant.
Independent of the number of
cards, I just need to say,
how many a's are there?
It could be anywhere
between 0 and n.
How many b's are there?
Between 0 and n.
How many c's are there?
So 26 numbers in
the range 0 to n--
I like to think of this as a
26-digit number base n plus 1.
We can map this
into base n plus 1.
And we get 26
digits In that base.
Another way to say it is
that the number of possible
combinations here-- how many
a's, how many b's, how many
c's--
is not even theta.
It is n plus 1, anything between
0 and n, to the power of 26.
This is a good polynomial.
So I can do stuff
like radix sort.
Cool.
So let me summarize a little
bit how we solve part a.
So I want to build a
data structure, which is,
for each value i,
I know I'm going
to end up serving these four
cards, or in general, k cards.
So for those cards, I
would like to compute
how many a's, how many b's,
how many c's are there?
And then just write
down this number.
This is a number
which I can write down
in at most 26 words, because we
can represent numbers between 0
and n in a single word.
That's the w is at
least log n assumption.
So it's constant size.
In a constant
number of numbers, I
can represent all I need to
know about a thing of size--
of length k here.
So I don't need to know
which letters is where.
I just need to know
the sorted order.
So I just need to know-- this
is called a frequency table--
how many a's, how many b's?
And so if I can compute those,
then given that representation
for starting at i, and
given that representation
for starting at j,
say, which would
be these two and these
two, I can compare them
by just comparing
those 26 numbers.
If they're all
equal, then they're
the same string after sorting.
And if there's any difference,
then they're different.
So that's how I could
do it in constant time
if I can compute
these representations.
And it's not hard to do that.
It's called a sliding window
technique, where you compute it
for the first k guys.
And then you remove this
item and add this item.
And just by incrementing
the counter for b,
decrementing the
counter for a, now
I know the representation
for these guys.
Make a copy of that, which is
a copy of those 26 numbers,
constant.
Then I add on c, remove b.
Then I add on a, remove c,
add on d, remove d, add on c,
remove b, and add
on d, and remove c.
Well, I got back
to the beginning.
So now I have
representation of those.
OK, so by sliding
this window, I'm
only changing at the two ends.
I add one guy on.
I increment one
of these counters.
I decrement one
So in constant time,
given the representation
of one of these substrings, I
can compute the representation
of the next one.
And that's how I,
in linear time,
can build such a
data structure that
lets me tell whether
any two hands are equal.
The next problem,
part b, is, given
all these
representations, can you
find which one is
the most common?
Because we were choosing
i uniformly at random,
I want to know what the most
likely hand that you get is.
And I think the
easiest way to say
this is you can do
that by radix sorting.
You take all these
representations.
They are nice numbers
in the range 0
to n plus 1 to the 26th power.
So I can just run radix
sort and sort them all.
And then with a single
scan through the array,
I can see which one
is the most common.
Or rather, I can--
in a single scan, I can compute,
OK, how many of the same things
are at the front?
If they're sorted, then all the
equal ones will be together.
So how many are there?
Then how many equal ones next?
And how many equal ones next?
Each time, comparing each
item to the previous one.
Then I get frequency counts
for all of these hands.
And then I do another scan
to find the most common one.
And I can do another scan to
find the lexically best one,
lexically last one.
And that's how you
solve problem 5.